♪ J'aurais pu être
influenceur ♪
- André-Philippe Gagnon,
vous nous avez émerveillés,
en 40 ans de carrière,
avec vos imitations.
Avec votre nouveau spectacle,
"Monsieur Tout le monde",
quelles sont vos nouvelles
imitations?
ANDRÉ-PHILIPPE GAGNON, imitateur
- Il me semble que j'ai trouvéut
Charlebois, qui s'en va
un peu vers le Jim Morrison,
son influence peut-être
quand il était plus jeune,
puis là, je peux faire un...
♪ Conception ♪
Puis, je peux faire quelque
chose qui s'approche assez.
Alors, il y a des...  nouvelles
voix que je peux me permettre.
Mais t'sais, Marc Hervieux...
♪ Et pouvoir dire pourquoi
j'existe ♪
Parce que je m'imaginais
toujours Marc Hervieux
en chantant une berceusepour un.
désolé pour le... le technicien
de son, mais attention...
(opéra)
♪ Fais dodo Colas ♪
Tu t'imagines le bébé!
Poc, poc, poc...
si ça prend ça pour l'endormir,
qu'est-ce que ça prend pour
le réveiller le petit pit...
(rires)
- Vous avez toujours le même
plaisir malin, ça se voit tout
de suite...
- Depuis que je suis petit aussi
que j'ai réalisé que... en
faisant des imitations, bien,
tu sais, ça... tu fais rire tout
le monde autour, là, t'sais,
puis... J'ai un frère que
j'adore, Fernand, qui...
bien, c'est lui, justement,
quand j'étais plus jeune,aiaiaiu
lui lâcher un Tweety Bird,
le petit oiseau dans Bugs Bunny.
Et puis lui, au lieu de me
chatouiller fort comme les
grands frères le font, il dit :
"maman, André fait Tweety Bird.
Le j'ai dit, attends un peu.
Si  lui pense que mon Tweety
Bird est assez bon, ça veut dire
que mon Mad Dog Vachon est prêt,
que mon Jean Béliveau est prêt,
ma Diane Dufresne est correcte,
mon Yvon Deschamps, j'en avais
quelques-uns que je faisais...
- Vous devez votre carrière
à votre frère?
- Bien, pas pire. Tu sais,
ça s'enligne là-dessus.
Fernand, il ne faut pas partir
en peur avec ça mais je pense
bien que oui.
(rires)
Il ressemble à quoi,
Tweety Bird, en 2021?
- I thought I saw a pussycat.
♪ Ah ♪
- (imitation de :::::::
I thought I saw a pussycat.
- Avec ma petite voix d'enfant
de huit ans, je pense que
mes hautes éeueueueueueueurs
et puis...
(voix grave)
Là maintenant, Tweety Bird a
cédé la place à Darth Vader.
(rires)
You may rest
in peace, Tweety Bird.
(rires)
(saxophone): Euh...
Pas tellement...
- Justement, vos débuts, c'était
aux "Lundis des Ha! Ha!".
Vous avez imité... l'homme
au saxophone, là.
(imitation d'un sa
C'est les débuts, ça.
- Oui, j'écrivais ça
complètement avec des jeux de
mots de trompette, clarinette,
sax, tvovovovovovovovoye donc!
(voix de saxophone)
Mais c'était ça,
la vie dans le temps.
On prenait un petit...
(imitation d'un saxophone)
Ça aussi, c'est un mélange de...
quand tu mets ta langue en
cuillère en bas puis aussi
le son de Roger Wittaker.
Tu fais...
(imitation d'un saxophone)
C'est comme, il y a ces deux
mélanges-là qui font le...
saxophone.
(rires)
- Would you welcome, please,
André-Philippe Gagnon!
(applaudissements)
- Vous célébrez 40 ans
de carrière, mais ça va faire az
22 ans au "Tonight Show"
avec Johnny Carson,
"We Are the World".
♪ We are the world ♪
♪ We are the children ♪
♪ We are the ones
who make a brighter day ♪
♪ So let's start giving ♪
- Et le petit truc que je
vous révéler, c'est que l'agent,
mon agent, à l'époque,
a refusé une première date
du "Tonight Show" parce que
j'étais à Saint-Prosper-de-
Beauce, cette date-là.
Alors mon agent ne voulait pas
perdre un client. Il aimait ça
dire : "He's not available."
Fait que...
(rire)
Alors, ils ont rappelé.
"Le 15, est-ce qu'il est
disponible?"
"He is available, yes."
Alors, moi, j'ai su ça plusieur.
bien, en tout cas.
♪ What a wonderful world ♪     ♪
- Vous êtes un véritable
marathonien de la scène.
Comment faites-vous, soir après
soir, pour garder votre voix
intacte? Parce que
c'est difficile, là.
- J'imite cette grande
chanteuse, notre plus grande
chanteuse, Céline Dion,
et j'ai la chance d'être...
de faire sa première partie
en 98, dans Let's Talk
About Love Tour. Puis de
grininininininininininine,
c'est certain que...
t'apprends, là, t'sais.
Et puis de... justement de...
elle, quand elle termine
ses spectacles, c'est...
pas un mot. Ses rencontres,
avant, elle les fait avant,
justement, prendre des photos...
Puis après le spectacle, c'est :
Céline a quitté le building.
C'est fini. Et puis, bien moi,
après, au lieu de
comme... avec les gens ou quand
on va manger ou quelque chose,
bien c'est... Je me la ferme.
Si j'ai parlé tr
(voix grave): Il va y avoir
cette voix-là, le matin, qui va
s'installer, puis là, oh boy! ds
faire pour faire les Bee Gees
ce soir? Puis là, bien,
t'essaies de faire un peungngng.
(voix cassée): Ha... ha... ha.
(rire)
On est loin de...
T'es pas là du tout, puis là...
Là, tu bois de l'eau, puis...
Alors, passer la journée comme
ça sur le stress pour savoirêêêr
ta musique le soir même, bien...
Cette technique-là de...
je vais l'appeler la technique
Céline, là, de... de seerererer.
d'attendre le lendemain,
juste pour faire un petit
"sound check" en après-midi.
Puis je fais un petit...
des fois, un petit genre...
(chant aigu)
... de "Star Trek" ou un...
(chant grave)VeVeVeVeVeVeVeVeVe.
(chant très grave)
(voix grave): I heard people say
that... avec un petit peu...
Mais Barry White, c'est jamais .
- André-Philippe Gagnon,
je n'ai jamais autant ri
pendant une entrevue.
Merci beaucoup.- Eille, merci Çé
très agréable. Merci pour
ton temps.
(rir